cet après midi là à lille de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines ces ateliers
théâtre pendant 1h30 parents et enfants
s'adonnent à des exercices
d'improvisation et de mise en situation
pour le mot clownesque j'ai bien aimé
d'être ici parce que il était très
gentil le monsieur et je me suis bien
amusé un frère
ça c'était cool parce que on pouvait
rigoler un petit peu parce qu'un
animateur il était drôle c'était assez
sympathique de pouvoir jouer un petit
peu avec avec la petite et puis avec ma
femme aussi c'était rigolo ça sorte un
petit peu notre 4 additionner une
animation parmi tant d'autres dans le
cadre de l'île de france fait le théâtre
pendant neuf jours la cinquième édition
de cette opération sous l'égide de la
région est organisée par les tréteaux de
france le centre dramatique national et
itinérants et fait découvrir le théâtre
sous toutes ses formes on va dans les
îles de loisirs dans trois îles de
loisirs de la région ile-de-france pour
amener le théâtre au devant des publics
qui n'ont pas l'habitude de venir donc
on est allé à draveil en est allé à
cergy pontoise et aujourd'hui on est à
saint quentin en yvelines on peut venir
pour goûter de la pratique du théâtre
pour le faire apprécier encore plus
[Applaudissements]
la programmation a été cette année
élargie avec la présence d'une deuxième
scène à proximité du village installé
dans l'île de loisirs aux côtés des
ateliers quatre compagnies venues de
toute la france présente également des
spectacles en extérieur et en intérieur
l'occasion de renouer avec la culture
mis sous cloche pendant plusieurs mois
ça fait du bien de sortir un petit peu
de voir du monde et de pouvoir interagir
avec des gens je trouve que c'est hyper
intéressant pour les enfants de
de leur faire découvrir le théâtre l'art
de la scène
j'aime bien beaucoup les spectacles des
fois ça dit sa jeune bien les histoires
et ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
il joue bien ça joue bien histoire
parfois c'est des histoires sans c'est
vrai c'est juste très bien de porter le
théâtre partout je pense que c'est pas
toujours accessible à tout le monde ici
ça l'est l'opération se déroule jusqu'au
29 août la programmation est gratuite
sur réservation notez que le pass
sanitaire est obligatoire pour assister
au spectacle sous chapiteau